you have a Netflix documentary you heard
to talk about called my own man and it's
the it's the filmmaker is in a search to
define his manhood is that yeah I'm fair
to say it's it's a this is a documentary
filmmaker I've produced two of his films
he's a terrific terrific filmmaker and
this film is unlike it really is unlike
almost anything I've seen in the sense
that he it took him over seven years to
make this film it's a it's a it's his
own investigation of how he felt about
having a son and and why he felt not as
connected to his own manhood and
adulthood as he wanted to and it and it
led him into an exploration of trying to
connect with masculinity more but then
also into into looking more at his own
relationship with his father Wow
and and I think it it for me I we showed
this moment to Tribeca Film Festival and
I I don't think I've ever been involved
in a dramatic film where people were
crying this hard at the end of the film
it's it's an incredibly funny and
touching and emotional film that touches
on many of the same things I think even
the great literature like Death of a
Salesman and and other things touch on
and I and I think we talked about Fight
Club but but in the same way that Fight
Club has that theme in it about like men
of our generation who don't feel they've
completely yet connected with with they
haven't they haven't actualized
themselves as men there's there's a lot
of that in this and I think it's very
very personal to him but very topical
and Universal for a lot of men you know
in terms of how do their fathers and
affect their own sense of what they want
to be in the world we have a clip here
from my own man anything we need to know
for this no I think it's pretty
self-explanatory no I do that film take
a look
[Music]
you once said that you felt like a boy
would be more challenging for you
because you also relate more to women in
your life yeah and I feel that way too
but I feel excited about that
it really feels different it really
feels like it's gonna be such a
discovery like it's just something so
new I didn't grow up with boys at all so
I feel like wow I get to experience this
thing that I didn't ever know before how
do you feel well um thrilled I'm
terrified actually I feel ready to be a
parent but being a father to a son isn't
just being a parent it means bringing a
boy into manhood a place I feel so far
away from myself variously to see my own
man it it is available on Netflix
starting on March 6th Edward Norton
thank you you are a busy guy
you